I'm Sarah I'm ANCA and we are again
trying kids science experiments as
adults last timing that you told me that
you have never done the potato light
bulb science experiment I am very
familiar with potatoes taco with the
tale the potato potatoes blue potato yes
I went to school in Idaho I didn't know
that but I don't know what the potato
light is okay well it's a challenge and
if we don't quite make it yeah we're
gonna have to bring in another expert
which is most likely a kid yeah if
you're ready to go I think we can put
this divider up divide us alright so I
was given the ingredients to this
experiment and so we're gonna see if we
can figure it out without seeing the
directions okay what we have in front of
us need potatoes pennies zinc-plated
nails some copper wire a little small
light bulb oh and then also tiny clock
all right and our goal is to light up
this tiny up this little light right
here so the clock requires less voltage
than the light so getting that working
will let us know if we're on the right
path does it actually work
well you're not just making this up I'm
not making this up this is a real thing
okay whenever you're ready okay
[Music]
I don't know why I already started
cutting up the potato a bunch like I
don't know whether if this isn't as
necessary
but now that I think about it like when
I think of an image of a potato light
bulb it's like the light bulb stuck in
the potato so maybe I'm wrong I don't
know
hi I'm just confused because I'm like
I'm not sure where the electricity is
coming from these are all like things
that you can use a conductive but we
need a source right like I'm trying to
remember what I we did in in seventh
grade oh wait I just got an idea
Gatorade has electrolytes and I'm pretty
sure that's something that the potatoes
need so I'm gonna go get some Gatorade
okay but I look so stupid in a video Oh
No start so can some of these I don't
put my glasses on I'm gonna look like an
idiot but these are gonna help me I
think
they say get electrocuted
[Music]
[Applause]
is it crazy if I just stab this into the
potatoes
stabby into the potato this is just like
nifty stuff I can do that it's difficult
to deal with these tiny objects and
children have tiny fingers so it's like
an unfair advantage of course it's gonna
be easier for them maybe all the wires
like need to be connected to each other
like do you I mean kind of like the
internet okay does that look great it
doesn't look great
certainly doesn't look right but I think
this is one of those things that looks
ugly it's like an ugly thing are you
just thinking about what you wish you
were cooking with these potatoes yeah I
can smell them it smells very good
[Applause]
oh I got it I got a number on the clock
I got 1200 bets that means it's turned
on and okay okay okay okay fine
okay we'll try it with the light because
you have to in order to win you have
together with the light okay how much
time do we have left one minute okay
all right I feel okay okay this is come
on Claire swatters
[Music]
okay all right so I guess you guys can
take this away now I guess whoa I got
the clock working I don't really know
how we must have made a circuit yeah I
mean like I know it's supposed to
connect to something you know like this
was much harder than I thought it would
oh no I did not even I totally did not
expect to go anywhere with us we just
wasted so many potatoes you could have
eaten right so many fries so many mashed
potatoes
I'm very sorry because we are gonna
waste more potatoes we are bringing in a
science expert once again to show us how
to do this project all right come on in
oh boy hi all right so I guess you're
the science expert yeah it's like okay
like how old are you
I'm 11 years old I'm in sixth grade have
you done this before yes it's pretty
easy okay leave it off for you though
fine okay all right I'm sorry
I spilled the first time I gave you a
chance meeting failed to take off your
lab coats they don't deserve it yet okay
I guess you're right Vegas oh you're
right you're right you're absolutely
right well all right maybe we'll earn it
back okay so let's do the experiment huh
first cut the potato in half boiled
makes it easier to cut but that doesn't
mean easy easier hidden kind of small
slip into each half large enough to
slide a penny right inside then you wrap
the copper wire around the pennies then
you have to use a different piece for
each pen put the little pennies and the
little slips simple it's a potato
addressed to penny then you wrap the
copper wire around some of the nails you
stick the zinc nails into the potato and
the nail
you can't touch how do you know what
goes where I've done this like five
million times make sure all the wires
are connected you finally take the two
loose ends and connect it to the light
you know let's just test it on this
little mini clock that we have to see
come on baby
Hey okay there you go so there is enough
voltage to do the clock lock okay so the
long end going that slightly longer and
you kind of wrap the wire the shorter
end goes with the zinc now it's not
working it's not working folks it's
close but what do we do then give me the
light up you need more voltage which
means you need more potatoes hold on so
potatoes actually do have voltage well
they have electrolytes which is what's
in batteries I feel like we should all
be using potatoes right you need to
charge your iPhone you could absolute
air drops okay Wow that's our oh that's
a really hard call you say tater tots
we have so many potatoes out here this
has to work great how are you feeling
Inga nervous nervous I was only Emily
also kind of worried is it gonna
electrocute no right
what do you think what might have
electrocute us maybe okay so thank you
all right so go ahead you're you I've
got this one you guys look at this
lighting up its bunch of different
colors oh my god that light looks really
cool disco light shining down psycho
Brady pork and Jones Anatomy Wow we I
mean but what happens if you don't have
potatoes you know like how are you gonna
can also use lemons and would juice
which is pretty cool
oh that might have smelled better I wish
we did that and again you want lemon
juice or tea to your eyes you're right
that's dangerous we've learned a lot
today and we know how to make a potato
light and you guys can do it too
who knew I mean everybody has potatoes
at home right it's a fun experiment kids
can try it adults can try it but until
next time
but we do it fail our crazy little
science experiment maybe we succeed or
maybe we all right probably not oh thank
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]